[Music]
hey you came back good to see you again
how's your mother we are now entering
the time of year when the biggest games
release september kicks this off with a
host of triple-a behemoths mass sports
titles hit their annual window and a few
souls like games try to grab your
attention here's my 9 picks for the most
wanted games for September 2019 as usual
let me know if you'd like me to play any
of these games on the channel my
personal hype train is heading straight
towards Borderlands 3 I'm sure you've
seen the copious amounts of advertising
the borderlands series was a pioneer
when it comes to the looter shooter
genre and although games like the
division of destiny took that in a
completely different direction
Borderlands 3 has stayed completely
loyal to its origins a loot driven
first-person shooter played in solo or
cooperatively with up to four players
and when I say loot wow I mean it
flamethrowers rocket launchers guns with
legs guns that fire hamburgers and every
gun could have a perk maybe elemental
damage maybe a different firing type
it's ridiculous how many guns are in
this game in a recent play test I found
a sniper rifle it was pretty damn good
and then I used the alternative fire
which made it into a chain gun my mind
is blown waddle on three is brilliantly
ridiculous guns are only one aspect to
the unique art style the brilliantly
written characters are with their own
slapstick sense of humor and the story
can draw you into this time it revolves
around a group of vault hunters hunting
vaults yes I have a real way with words
the only problem is that the children of
the vaults led by a dastardly set of
twins are also after those vaults let's
see who comes out on top
Badlands three releases on ps4 PC and
the Xbox one on September the 13th come
back later this week for a breakdown of
everything you need to know about
Borderlands 3
[Music]
the next game completely snuck up on us
all have you seen greed fall greet fall
is a pseudo 17th century fantasy themed
role-playing game which has impressed
many pre viewers we will explore the
island of Tia Freddy as we strive to
find a cure and heal our people from a
mysterious disease as we delve deeper we
realize this world is filled with
supernatural Guardians we can hunt them
down we can interact with people using
diplomacy or deceive everyone and
manipulate people from the shadows greed
false cinematics and voice acting look
impressive but what about those
mechanics from the first step we can
customize our character from looks to
starting skills attributes and talents
combat though depends on the spec of
your character such as relying on magic
to hit enemies from afar maybe or armory
not to go head to head with a heavy sort
hey and if that's not your thing and
bring out the traps the bombs the poison
darts the rifles the fighting mechanics
look varied oh and look at this one
tactical pause mid-fight you can freeze
time and give yourself the ability to
analyze the battlefield plotting your
next move which enemy to focus on and
instantly go back into the fight as soon
as you are ready this could be a
game-changing mechanic everything in
greet bot is customizable allowing you
to look and play the way you want greet
fall releases on the ps4 PC Xbox one on
September the 10th I have a feeling this
will be a big hit
[Music]
as it's September the annual sports
titles make their return first up it's
football both fifa and PES release their
updates this month but PES aka Pro
Evolution Soccer has had a name update
efort ball PES from now on this is
likely due to how the word soccer is
treated outside of North America people
thought they don't like that word in
terms of new features FIFA leads the way
yet again with almost every pro player
under the Sun represented and recreated
on the other hand be football PES 2020
only has a handful of licenses but that
does include Barcelona at Aventis and
Bayern Munich FIFA's improvements
include redesigned one-on-one situations
and the general flow of games has been
tweaked to make it feel a little less
Arkady and a little more like simulation
there are new inputs to master such as
strafing dribbling and a refresh free
kick mechanic to be football PES 2020 on
the other hand has improved the
long-loved Master League mode with
legendary managers and the new response
system making it possible to react to
people and change the storyline each
season if you're a football fan
you probably already know which one
suits you so let's not dwell here for
too long
FIFA 20 drops on September the 27th with
a football PES 2020 a fortnight earlier
on September the 10th
just in case I'm concentrating on
football or soccer too much September
also gives us NBA 2k 20 you already know
what basketball is so let's not go
through that so instead let's look at
the improvements from last year's
edition which include or rather exclude
the pushing mechanic which made many
people in the community unhappy and the
complete removal of unskipable in-game
advertising yes that really was a thing
in 2k 19 forced advertising within a
game which costs money to play in the
first place
ouch two NBA 2k 20 releases on September
the 6th on ps4 switch Xbox and the PC
and by the sounds of it they want to win
back the respect of their fans this
month also brings us NHL 20 but to go
through all the improvements in that
game will literally take 10 minutes at
least the main ones I took from this is
that there are 400 more animations so
the game looks better and the AI now
doesn't scar on goals all the time it
did when I played happy days if you love
ice hockey grab this on September the
13th
did you ever play the search it's
surprisingly good I only know that
because it was free on PS plus a few
months back well by complete coincidence
the surge too is coming out this
September just over two years after the
first one the game has many similarities
to the Dark Soul series but with a
futuristic setting the game begins in
Jericho city which has been quarantined
due to the city suffering from a
technically state all movement is
watched and the military is more than
happy to have a fight with you
and that's where the excel rigs come in
we are wearing an outer shell which is
upgradable for example during fights is
possible to concentrate on one area such
as someone's arm and after wearing it
down you can rip it off completely and
use the parts to upgrade improve and
learn new abilities for our rig and this
becomes the core mechanic the devs have
tried to evolve from the first game by
implementing other options than a
frontal assault every time you see an
enemy alternate route secret tunnels and
even helping NPCs can open new paths to
circumvent battles but at some point
your fighting skill will be tested
timing and tactics are imperative the
surge is a little more forgiving than
say Sakura but it's still firmly in the
souls barn mould the surge to releases
on September the 24th on ps4 PC and Xbox
one
[Music]
we also have a racing game for you this
month
WRC 8 the World Rally Championship
concentrating on being the best rally
driver ever and I mean concentrating one
early turn or late break will result in
catastrophe this is a racing simulation
WRC eight is the 15th game in the series
and boasts the most realistic and
authentic racing ever seen dynamic
weather which impacts traction and
visibility and 50 teams 14 countries and
100 tracks to race through this is gonna
be intense
another large improvement is the Korea
mode which adds to the immersion and
stress of being a world-class rally
driver so perfect you're right six into
the left hairpin and you can be the
world champion WRC eight crashes in two
stars on September the fifth on ps4 Xbox
one and PC oh and switch to and finally
September sees the return of Monster
Hunter World the major expansion named
ice-born arrives if you're new to the
genre pick up a weapon and track down a
monster in a fully realized habitat
filled with countless other monsters so
my passive but most are aggressive
especially when you hit them with a
10-foot sot ice bond takes us to a
completely new hunting ground with new
and old monsters to murder and make into
armor and that's where the core cycle is
track kill calf it's very easy to become
addicted here's a few extras though we
can now tame and ride upon smaller
beasts in the world and layered armor
looks like another interesting addition
and I suppose it's only right to wrap up
warm when you're venturing into a new
snowy world most of the world I spawn
dlc hits ps4 and the Xbox one on
September the 6th and surprisingly the
update won't make its way to PC for a
few months yet
[Music]
whoa we did it there we have it what
floats your boat this month I cannot
wait to jump back into bottle under
three I've already played almost 20
hours and they already want to play more
grief are also has me interested but
what about you
I'll be snooping around in the comments
to see oh and I also owe you an apology
from last month I said that the
free-to-play game Caravan stories was
coming out in the month of August when
in fact it had been postponed in Europe
and North America to an undisclosed date
many people are suggesting actually we
won't get to us until March 2020 so I'm
very sorry if I'm not researching
further before letting you guys know my
bad a completely held and hold my hands
up to that one I hope you can't forgive
me I'm Adam from PlayStation grenade
thanks for sticking around till the end
I'll see you next time
[Music]